[Music]
chrissy teigen gives birth to baby
number two little boys necks for sure
congratulations are in order for the 32
year old model and her husband John
Legend the pair welcomed their second
child together
a baby boy we want to have more I don't
know the timing but we definitely want
to have at least a couple of months
Christie and John are already parents to
their two-year-old daughter Luna is when
excited to be she is so excited she
actually she's got her little baby doll
now that she's been really taken care of
the lip-sync battle star adorably
announced she and John were expecting on
Instagram in November and et spoke with
Chrissy in January where she opened up
about preparing for the newest addition
to the family I think the balance is
hard I mean you know you want to be able
to give one so much attention and shower
them with love and affection and within
you a little baby - and I thought be
rough to balance but I'm excited to
figure it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]